nice conflans sainte honorine paris ces
trois villes ont été le théâtre
d'attentats depuis le début de l'automne
des attaques survenues quelques semaines
avant la commémoration qui marque les
cinq ans des attentats du 13 novembre
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
la menace terroriste a parfois pu se
faire oublier mais elle est bel et bien
là c'est en tout cas ce qu'a confié
cette source sécuritaire à nos confrères
de la fp on a pu avoir l'impression que
la menace était passé au deuxième plan
parce que d'autres problématiques ont
émergé les gilet jaune le coc vide mais
en réalité les chiffres montrent bien
qu'elle est restée élevée depuis 2015
en cinq ans 20 attentats ont été commis
sur le sol français
19 ont échoué et 61 ont été déjoués les
trois attaques survenues à récemment ont
poussé le gouvernement à porter le plan
vigipirate à son niveau maximal urgence
attentes à une réévaluation à qui a
aussi été décidé en raison de la
conjonction de plusieurs facteurs
dans le contexte de république à sion
des caricatures de mahomet par charlie
hebdo le 2 septembre 2020 la france et
pour la première fois depuis les
attentats de janvier 2015 l'objet de
trois attaques terroristes en moins d'un
mois le 25 septembre 2020 à paris le 16
octobre 2020 à eragny et le 29 octobre
2020 à nice compte tenu des
circonstances
le premier ministre a décidé d'élever le
niveau vigipirate à son niveau urgence
attentat sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
il menace qui n'est pas propre à la
france l'attentât du 2 novembre dernier
devienne perpétré par un sympathisant de
dèche démontre que l'ensemble des pays
européens peuvent être touchées emmanuel
macron à d'ailleurs appelé aller
ensemble des chefs d'états de lieux a
trouvé une réponse coordonnée et rapide
à la menace terroriste
il a aussi plaidé pour un renforcement
de la sécurité en europe dans l'hexagone
plusieurs textes en lien avec le
j'ai sont dans les tuyaux le projet de
loi contre le séparatisme islamiste
devrait être présenté en conseil des
ministres le 9 décembre prochain et une
nouvelle loi pour le renseignement
devrait être présenté pour l'été 2021